all righty i am back um
two quick things one you guys better get
my subscribers up real quick cause i'm
damn close to doing a day in the life of
a google software engineer video i swear
don't make me do it it'll be very cringy
second of all is i have a nice big
collaboration coming up with uh a
decently big youtuber which is sweet so
hopefully that'll get some numbers up on
here but
i don't know it's not really a huge deal
at the end of the day i'm kind of just
doing this to self-study and it's
actually working out pretty well i feel
like i'm getting pretty good at this
stuff so anyway let's go ahead and look
into bloom filters because this is
something i've mentioned for a while and
i would kind of be a hypocrite if i just
talked about them all the time and never
explained how they actually worked so
let's go ahead and do
all that
bloom filters what are they basically
bloom filters are just another data
structure that you use to approximate
the contents of a set so i've kind of
mentioned that before but basically
they're a probabilistic algorithm that
will tell you conclusively if something
is
not in the set so basically you don't
ever have to worry about false negatives
but that being said bloom filters may
basically take an element and say this
could be in the set so you may have to
search this and then you have to do a
little bit of unnecessary work to find
out if it's actually in there so let's
go ahead and look at some use cases
where bloom filters are used because
i've mentioned one big one but there's
another that seems to be pretty common
in a lot of large scale systems
and that is going to be cache filtering
so imagine
you know maybe we're just google and
we're going to be a search index and
we are going to cache a bunch of the
common results of search terms that our
end client might use a lot so imagine
i'm on my phone or on my laptop or
something and generally speaking i
search the term coding a lot because i'm
a nerd and i've been doing a lot of
research on this my phone like the idiot
that it is goes and thinks that i'm
talking about cuddling
so first i'm going to search cuddling
and maybe i do search that sometimes
because i'm down bad but
search cuddling and then this thing
that's going to happen is that it's
going to go to the cache the cache is
going to see the cuddling's not in there
the cache doesn't have that much space
so what's going to end up happening is
it might evict a term that i use a lot
more such as coding
this is bad obviously i never even meant
to search cuddling
but it was just an autocorrect so how
can we actually go ahead and provide
some layer of protection to not
basically go ahead and cache terms that
i've really never searched before
this would kind of be where a bloom
filter would come in so how would we go
ahead and do this well first you know on
that search term cuddling we would go
ahead and check if that is in the bloom
filter and basically if the bloom filter
says no it's not it means that i
personally have never searched the word
cuddling before and like i said there
are no false negatives so the balloon
filter knows that for sure if i haven't
ever searched cuddling before it's not
only not going to probably be in the
cache but more importantly
we don't want to go ahead and pull
results from that into the cache so we
would just go ahead and reroute my
request straight to the database because
it's probably a pretty
uncommon request and as a result it
won't be a big deal if these uncommon
requests go to the database because
we're not hammering it it's
it's mostly the common request that it's
mostly important that they go to the
cache because that way it stops the
database from having to handle most of
the load
so anyways like i said if that's not in
the bloom filter
we go ahead and search the results for
cuddling in the database of the search
index or whatever it may be but the
point is we are skipping around that
cache so in this sense bloom filters are
allowing us to get better cache
performance
another common use case that i've talked
about in the past are ss tables so
recall that for lsm based storage
engines
we first on reeds check the lsm tree
which is an in-memory tree like a red
black tree or something and then we go
ahead and search every single ss table
in order from newest to oldest to try
and see if we can go ahead and find that
key
however
that's really bad because we can
actually go ahead and have to search
every single ss table and actually
searching an ss table means running a
binary search on it because it's sorted
from basically the entire bounds of the
table from the beginning to the end but
what if instead we were to use bloom
filters on each ss table
so that we could basically very
efficiently tell if a key was not in
that ss table and if so skip over it
obviously we don't have a 100 success
rate here they're going to be times
where the bloom filter says well
actually we think the key is in here so
you're still going to have to check it
and then it turns out it's not and you
go forwards but even still generally
speaking this saves a lot of time so if
you see my example below basically i
would check the bloom filters for ss
table 1 and 2 for the key jordan and
hopefully the bloom filter would tell me
jordan's not in there and as a result i
would then look at the bloom filter for
ss table 3. it would say jordan might be
in here and then i would go ahead and
run binary search and find my proper key
the point is though just remember that
like i said it's possible that the bloom
filter for either ss table 1 or 2 would
say that jordan is actually in there and
if so i would waste some time searching
those tables to no avail
so why is it that bloom filters actually
work this way well let's go ahead and
break down the algorithm for them
so basically the way that bloom filters
work is the following you start with a
single array of m bits initialized to
zeros so bits can basically just be
zeros or ones and we have this array of
length m
okay so now what we're going to do is
choose k different hash functions and
obviously we want these to be good hash
functions in the sense that they
distribute our data relatively uniformly
and they're random
so imagine i have the key poop whatever
that's what i chose that's right i'm not
mature
basically we're going to go ahead and
take each of the k hash functions so
imagine here that k is 3. so i have
these three hash functions and take the
result of them mod m
so imagine i hatched poop three times
with these three functions and the
results i get are 0 2 and m minus 1.
what we're going to do is say if i
wanted to add poop to these to this set
the bloom filter that i would use to
represent this set now i have to set all
of these bits from the hashes of poop to
one
so you can you can see now that in the
array i've set the zeroth bit to one the
second bit to one and the m minus one
bit to one so this is kind of how i
would go ahead and add a term if i were
to add more terms you know if i wanted
to add p or something i would go ahead
and do the same exact hashes and i would
continue to add the bits it would be on
the same array by the way not a
different array so keep that in mind we
just have one array and every single
time we're adding a term we're setting
the corresponding bits in that single
array so you can see how that might be a
problem later but we'll talk about that
in a bit
so now to continue the actual algorithm
we now have this set that just contains
poop and we have the corresponding bits
from the hashes of poop that are all set
so now imagine if i wanted to get the
hash results for the key jordan so i
would go ahead and use those same k hash
functions and go ahead and get the
results so hash function 1 of jordan mod
m return 0 2 gets 2. so as you can see
jordan and poop are actually pretty
similar in the way they're hashed uh you
know random i guess luck but even still
the fact that hash function three mod um
returns three as opposed to m minus one
means that jordan and poop differ in one
bit from those three hashes so since the
fact that filter three equals zero we
know that jordan can't be in the set
because if jordan was in the set that
bit would have been set to one
as a result we can basically
conclusively say that we are able to
basically in uni uh in constant time
determine if something is in the set and
in this case we know that jordan is not
so now you might be thinking to yourself
well what if we've added so many
elements to the set that
basically we just get lucky unlucky and
um you know it just so happens that bits
zero two and three have already been set
to one and now we just think that jordan
is in the set even though it's not well
in this case we're out of luck so
basically like i said as we add more
elements to the set more of the bits in
that array are going to start being set
to ones and sometimes we're going to get
false positives
obviously there's not really much we can
do here
there is math basically you know getting
values for m and k where m is the length
of that array and k or the number of
hash functions you know to try and avoid
a good number of false positives but at
the end of the day after a while when
there are too many things in the set
occasionally we're just going to have to
go ahead and reset that bloom filter to
all zeroes to avoid getting so many
false positives because eventually it's
just going to even stop being useful and
if every single time is an error then it
doesn't even help us to go ahead and
check that out we may as well just reset
it to zero
incur the penalty of you know having to
re-add some things to the set and then
eventually start getting useful bloom
filter results again
okay so in conclusion bloom filters are
super useful in terms of both that
cash filtering that i mentioned and also
lsm reads um there's something that i've
mentioned a lot and i've put an emphasis
in this channel of trying to explain
every single thing that i can
you know within reason and so i think
it's really useful to kind of be able to
actually go ahead and break this down
and see this technique that's used in so
many modern database systems in order to
greatly improve the speed of reads in
the past i've kind of acted like this
was some sort of you know probabilistic
algorithm where you know it
can almost get things wrong sometimes
and the truth of the matter is no it
can't really get things wrong if a bloom
filter says something is not in a set
it's right about that and so you may
have to end up doing you know a similar
amount of work because you're just going
to falsely search a set for something
that's not there but it can still speed
things up a lot by telling you that some
element is not in a set and that is
hugely important for a variety of
reasons and i kind of went through those
use cases in this video so i think that
being able to talk about bloom filters
in a systems design interview is pretty
useful and at the end of the day i hope
this video